y las promesas hechas en la cop 26 están
en duda durante la cumbre de glasgow
brasil se mostró dispuesto a cumplir con
sus compromisos climáticos
favorecemos acciones y proyectos para la
conservación de los bosques el uso
racional de los recursos naturales la
mitigación de las emisiones de gases de
efecto invernadero y sobre todo la
creación de empleos verdes
simples el gobierno dé bolsonaro anunció
en glasgow la reducción de las emisiones
de gases de efecto invernadero en un 50
por ciento para 2030 y dijo que está
dispuesto a acabar con la deforestación
ilegal en 2028 dos años antes de lo
previsto sin embargo para científicos y
activistas las promesas sirven de poco
cuando la deforestación sigue avanzando
y tienden a empeorar bajo el gobierno de
bolsonaro un presidente que ha promovido
la minería y la ganadería extensiva los
datos preliminares del instituto
nacional de investigación espacial de
brasil son alarmantes muestran que la
amazonía brasileña la más extensa selva
tropical del mundo perdió 877 kilómetros
cuadrados de cobertura vegetal tan sólo
en octubre al respec tomar yo astrini
secretario ejecutivo del observatorio
del clima dijo en twitter en plena
conferencia climática las alertas de
deforestación de octubre batieron un
récord histórico subió un 5% más que el
año pasado la cruda realidad del suelo
del bosque acaba de desenmascarar el
discurso fantasioso del ministro de
medioambiente y su gobierno los
científicos de la cope en 26 aseguran
además que la amazonía está en código
rojo y sólo frenando su devastación se
evitará que llegue a un punto
catastrófico de no retorno los expertos
afirman que si se mantiene los índices
de deforestación ese punto de inflexión
llegaría antes de 2050